-America's three months
into a coronavirus pandemic,
and at this point
we've all been told
to wash our hands
about 2 million times.
But what's the right way
to do it?
Here to tell us is one of ou
writers, Jenny Hagel.
-Hey, Seth.
-Hey, Jenny.
So what is the right way
to wash your hands?
-Great question.
To make sure your hands
are germ-free,
wash them for 20 seconds.
Make sure you wash the tops of
your hand, to your palms,
your thumbs, and the tips
of your fingers.
If you do that
12 to 24 times a day,
your hands will be
in great shape.
-Oh, my God!
Jenny.
-What?
Is something wrong?
-Jenny, your hands --
they don't look so good.
-Oh.
Do they look a little dry?
-Yes.
-That's from
all the hand washing.
But, there's an easy way
to solve that.
Every time you wash your hands
be sure to moisturize
with lotion.
Apply a generous amount, and
then just rub it in thoroughly
And if you do that, your hands
will be silky smooth.
-Jenny, are your hands okay?
-They sure are.
By washing my hands regularly,
I can be sure of three things.
One, I'm keeping myself safe
Two, I'm keeping others safe
And three, I'm getting
in a habit of good hygiene
It's like the CDC says --
Ooh, I need my reading glasses
Excuse me.
There we go.
"When you wash your hands,
you protect your community."
Well, Seth,
you know who has two thumb
and loves her community?
This gal.
-Jenny, I'm looking closel
at your hands,
and I can't help but notice...
-I know.
It's hard not to notice.
-I mean, I don't want to b
forward, but --
-You can say it.
-Can I say it?
-I'll say it.
I got engaged!
Look at my ring!
-I mean, congratulations, bu
that's not what I was gonna say.
-My fiancée and I
are so happy.
-Oh, she washes her hands too.
-Seth, even in these dark times,
there can still be a little joy.
If we just think to ourselves,
"What's something I can do
to help the world?
Is there some small thing
that I can do -- me --
to help everyone?"
And the answer is,
wash your hands.
If you're doing that,
let me tell you,
you deserve a high-five.
[ Clatters ]
Oh, no, my ring!
-Jenny Hagel, everybody.
Oh... [mutters]
-Bye!